Danny is with us in Houston Texas hey
Danny welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you thank you hi Daddy better than
I deserve what's up all right so the
story is my brother put me in depth of
six grand with Amazon that count that
show to a debt collector and now I'm
dealing with them how did your brother
put you in that he signs your name
yeah order me this is not his first time
doing it so he has like my information
and stuff like that
oh so your brother's a thief yes yeah
yeah there's a crook yeah yeah oh my god
you don't know this money you don't have
to pay debt if somebody steals your
identity it's not your dad
what if I do father's fraud and
everything goes ah sweet to jail yeah
that debt then huh if it still had more
yeah it's him they don't that you don't
know the money okay no I don't I doubt
they'll put him in jail they probably
should he's a thief but I mean and then
this has happened before
yeah when I was younger like in my high
school or college years I heard about my
parents and sister talking about it my
parents actually took care of that debt
he felt big whenever that was I had no
idea
yeah when I was younger but you know and
how long when this Amazon Amazon icon
has opened suspect 2016 now when did you
discover it earlier this week when the
debt collectors calling me Oh this week
is the first time you heard about it
yeah okay good good okay have you talked
to your mother about this I checked them
here actually a voice my phone calls so
this is actually called his wife and I
think that's the only person that can
kind of get due to him to talk some
sense into them you know so yeah well
just go ahead and tell her you're gonna
file a police report
because you have to to get rid of this
and get in touch with the debt collector
and get in touch with Amazon and let
them know that this is identity theft
and you actually know who the crook is
you're required to tell them by law if
you know who the crook is okay and so
I'm not trying to throw him under the
bus but he threw himself in front of the
bus okay by doing this so you can't pay
this bill you you really can't you're
going to get yourself in a mess if you
do so call the debt collector back and
say this is hold are you okay
call the debt collector back and tell
them that this is not your debt that
your identity has been stolen you think
you know who it is and you will be
filing a police report that you can
forward to them what procedure do they
have for you to file an identity theft
claim with them because you are not
paying this I talked to my financial
coach he says I do not owe this money
and for me not to pay it because you
just talk to me and I'm your financial
coach another quick question then are
you gonna do that other goods well I
want to sell this and the people never
were my brother doesn't get charged with
the criminal record and he just pays the
debt because how did he get a job if he
if he has a criminal area great so
that's my thought that's kind of his
problem cuz he's kind of a crook yeah
and he did it before you know why you
settle this again you're gonna settle it
he's gonna do it again he won't even
return your call he won't even return
your call to say I'm sorry yeah he acts
like he's entitled to rob a bank yeah
yeah well he should be but he's not
trustworthy is he I'm sorry man I know
it breaks your heart and you're trying
to be a nice guy about it but listen the
only way I would cut this guy some slack
is if he called you back like
instantaneously went man I'm so sorry I
screwed up so bad I'm gonna pay this and
I promise I'll never do it again
and I'm gonna get paid by the end of the
week
you know if he started acting that way
but he won't even own it yeah
dude I mean and here's the thing he's
not gonna go to jail they're not gonna
prosecute him they're too lazy to
prosecute him they're gonna write it off
and they're gonna put a black mark on
his name and that's all they're gonna do
I mean they might they can but they're
not going to they're not that they're
just not that aggressive they're too
lazy okay so they might I mean there's
I'll tell you there's a 5% chance that
they follow it all the way through but I
doubt they will I doubt very seriously
they will and if they do then it's it's
his fault he's the one that chose to be
a bank robber see when you use a gun or
when you use someone else's identity and
you steal money from a bank in either
case you're a bank robber yep that's how
serious this is this is criminal fraud
so you do what you want to do dude but
that's what I would do if I were in your
shoes and I'm not trying to be mean to
him but I am saying that you know
there's a proper way to react to these
things he's not even on the radar of
proper reaction to this there's no
repentance there's no no no regret
there's no nothing he's just hiding from
you I have to call his wife to talk some
sense into him your older brother who
screwed you over I mean my goodness
no no the this is gonna keep happening
and keep happening until you stop it
from happening and if I were in your
shoes that's what I would do in this
scenario